>> Tucker: AT LEAST ONE
POLITICIAN IN EUROPE IS
FEARLESSLY RAISING AN ALARM
ABOUT THE KIND OF SOCIETY
EUROPEAN ELITES WANT TO CREATE.
ONE THAT HAS REJECTED
UNANIMOUSLY ALMOST BY THEIR
CITIZENS.
IN A SPEECH YESTERDAY KICKING
OFF THE PARTY'S BID FOR
REELECTION, GARY AND
PRIME MINISTER WARREN
POLITICIANS THAT THEY WILL
DESTROY WESTERN CIVILIZATION
WITH THEIR ENTHUSIASM FOR MASS
MIGRATION.
LEFT UNCHECKED, HE SAID EURO
COULD END UP WITH A MUSLIM
MAJORITY WHILE IT WOULD BE
BLOTTED OUT.
IT'S NOT CRAZY ON A MASS LEVEL
HERE.
THE BIRTHRATE IS NOT HIGH.
IT WOULDN'T TAKE A HUGE WAVE OF
IMMIGRATION FROM MUSLIM NATIONS
TO OVERRUN AND EVENTUALLY
OBLITERATE A CULTURE THAT'S BEEN
THERE FOR THOUSANDS OF YEAR.
IF YOU'VE BEEN THERE FOR A
MILLENNIUM, MAYBE YOU DO CARE.
THEY SHOW THAT MOST EUROPEANS
AGREE WITH THAT.
LAST YEAR MAJORITIES IN GERMANY,
FRANCE, BELGIUM AND SEVERAL
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT THEY WANTED
A TOTAL FREEZE ON IMMIGRATION
FROM MUSLIM COUNTRIES.
IT DENOUNCED THEM AS